Frau eskin die erste Frage vielleicht an
sie wie fanden sie es eigentlich dass
ihr Kanzler dass das Olaf Scholz die
Reise des Vizekanzlers zur
Weltklimakonferenz gcancelt hat das ist
ja nicht auf Weisung des Kanzlers
geschehen sondern die haben sich die
sitzen ja jetzt seit Tagen zusammen und
haben sich die Karten gelegt und haben
gesagt wir brauchen diese Zeit wir haben
ja einen ambitionierten Zeitplan wir
wollen am liebsten noch in diesem Jahr
den Haushalt verabschieden für 2024 ich
finde die Bevölkerung hat es auch
verdient jetzt Sicherheit zu bekommen
darüber was passiert und deswegen ist es
richtig wenn dort auch Termine abgesagt
werden das heißt das hat er ganz selber
gemacht ja eigenständig der wichtigste
Minister hab haben sich das gemeinsam
die haben sich das gemeinsam überlegt
und haben sind zu der Entscheidung
gekommen das und wie finden sie es in
dem Zusammenhang dass
250 Menschen nur von deutscher Seite an
dieser Klimakonferenz teilnehmen von der
glaube ich nur der kleinste Teil
wirklich übers Klima verhandelt und der
Rest macht was also alle solche Gipfel
sind ja immer auch von langerh
vorbereitet von vielen Menschen die da
auch mit dran mitarbeiten das sind ja
keine sind ja keine Gipfel wo sich
statenlinker treffen und sagen lasst uns
mal zusammenitzen und reden sondern da
ist ja viel vor besprochen und
vorgearbeitet und die das getan haben
die müssen auch da sein um dann eben
entsprechend auch mitarbeiten zu können
dann gibt es die NGOs die natürlich auch
ein Interesse dran haben die die
Nichtregierungsorganisation auch ein
Interesse dran haben Vorort
mitzubekommen was passiert insofern ist
klar dass so eine Delegation so groß ist
wir haben allerdings jetzt den
Nachrichten nachzuurteilen ja leider
kein ganz großes Ergebnis zu erwarten
jedenfalls sieht es im Moment 250 Leute
nur von deutscher Seite und es kommt
nichts raus das ist
ja nicht von deutscher Seite so dass wir
dafür sorgen dass nichts rauskommt
sondern das ist die Entwicklung der Welt
wie wie erklärt man das dem Steuerzahler
ja das ist ja nicht alleine auf auf
Steuerzahlerkosten wie gesagt das sind
ja auch nicht regierungsor
Organisationen dabei die nicht auf
Steuerzahlerkosten fliegen sondern auf
Kosten ihrer Organisation und dennoch
ist es schon so dass solche Gipfel
natürlich eine Menge Geld auch Kosten
aber am Ende geht es um ein wichtiges
Thema und die Hoffnung war groß
wichtiges Thema Klima mein sie absolut
aber das ist ja die Botschaft Wirtschaft
geht jetzt vor Klima das ist doch die
Botschaft nein die die die bot die
Botschaft der Kanzler war ja da und die
Außenministerin war ja da insofern das
war schon mal ziemlich wichtig dass der
klimaclub auch weiter entwickelt wird
und
wenn der wenn der Vizekanzler der
Wirtschaftsminister klimaminister
gemeinsam mit dem Bundeskanzler und dem
Finanzminister zu dem Schluss kommt dass
seine Anwesenheit jetzt dort nicht
notwendig ist oder jedenfalls nicht so
wichtig wie die Gespräche die sie führen
dann wird's wohl so sein ich schau
gerade mal zu Herrn Blome wie wie wie
schauen Sie auf so etwas na diese
Regierung fällt auseinander wenn sie
nicht in den nächsten 14 Tagen einen
Haushalt zusammengebacken kriegt das ist
die Königsdisziplin einer jeden
Regierung ohne Haushalt ist Schluss
insofern kann kann ich verstehen dass
der Vizekanzler der Grünen Partei gerne
dabei sein möchte um zu verhindern dass
er demnächst nicht mehr Vizekanzler ist
und das wird eben Tick wichtiger sein
ich finde wahrscheinlich auch subjektiv
oder Objektiv auch zurecht als einer von
80.000 ungefähr Teilnehmern an dieser
Konferenz zu sein die in der Tat glaube
ich sehr stark aufgeblätt ist ob die
Delegation der deutschen mit 250
deutlich zu groß ist oder nur ein
bisschen zu groß ist kann man
dahingestellt sein lassen es ist nur
überblät ja also ich weiß nicht wie man
mit 80.000 Menschen die parallel ja
miteinander reden wirklich verhandeln
kann oder ob das nicht in Wahrheit am
Ende in einem ganz kleinen Kreis
ausgeschossen wird so wie übrigens ja
das Haushaltsloch auch nicht in der
großen Ganzen Koalition zugemacht wird
sondern wenn in einer Runde dieser drei
Herren die wir da auf dem Bild sehen mhm
Herr Feld sie als Ökonom beschäftigen
sich mit sowas ja natürlich das
Klimathema ist ja eines der wichtigsten
aber 250 Leute und am Ende machen es ein
paar Leute aus und es kommt nichts be
rum das Problem ist eigentlich eher dass
die Klimaverhandlungen die wir
international in den vergangenen Jahren
beobachtet haben immer mehr zu einer
entwicklungspolitischen Veranstaltung
geworden sind und immer weniger fürs
Klima dabei rumk die Idee eines
klimaclubs mit vielen funktioniert eben
nicht besonders gut es ist wichtig dass
die drei großen Emittenten die EU die
USA und China einen klimaclub bilden und
das sind die Verhandlungen viel besser
eingesetzt auch mit kleineren
Delegationen okay also weg von dem Thema
das bietet den kleinen Ländern die sonst
diesen großen den Kreisen der großen
sonst gar nicht stattfinden würden keine
Stimme hätten die Gelegenheit einmal
ihren Punkt zu machen oder eine kleine
Insel die droht irgendwo im Pazifik zu
versinken hat da sein Forum ihr Forum
das hätte sie sonst nicht ich glaube das
ist ein Punkt man schon g lassen kann
aber trotzdem von esken 80.000 sind so
viel und 250 sind auch müssen wir müssen
wir nicht drüber diskutieren aber es
sind nicht nur die es ist nicht nur die
kleine Insel im im im Südpazifik die das
Problem hat und jetzt eben vorträgt was
ist den mit dem klimaäh Schutz sondern
es sind ja auch die Länder die jetzt auf
der an an der Schwelle zur Entwicklung
oder so mittendrin stecken und die jetzt
auch Gas geben wollen und wo wir dann
Gas geben ja guter Begriff wo wir ähm
Appelle richten und sagen äh also wir
müssten jetzt schon auch gucken dass ihr
euch klimaneutral entwickelt und dabei
nicht die notwendige Unterstützung zu
bekommen äh das das dürftte dürfte
problematisch sein und hat größere
Auswirkungen auf unser Weltklima als
unerecheidung alle zu unserem großen
Problem ja deswegen lass uns weg von dem
Thema ich ich würde sie gerne einmal
ganz offen fragen wie konnte es zu
diesem Chaos kommen verfassungswidriger
Haushalt wie konnte sowas passieren ja
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
entschieden dass eine eine Buchens und
haushaltspraxis die wir angewendet haben
nicht richtig und nicht der Verfassung
entsprochen hat und das müssen wir so zu
Kenntnis
nehmen offenkundig war offenkundig ein
Fehler na ja also ich ich würde ja jetzt
wenn ich jetzt sagen würde wir haben wir
wussten ja dass ist falsch ist aber wir
haben es trotzdem gemacht würden sie
auch erschrecken das ist natürlich nicht
nicht der Fall gewesen sonder wir haben
nein wir haben nach bestem Wissen und
Gewissen entschieden so so zu handeln ja
sie haben neulich deswegen frage ich so
nach bei der Kollegin maybrit ilner
einen schönen Satz dazu gesagt die
ampelparteien sind auf der Grundlage
auch dieses Tricks zusammengekommen den
man für verfassungsgemäß gehalten hat
genau und der ist nicht wahr sie haben
das Wort Trick benutzt
ja das ist der Gedanke wenn sie do
wissen das ist der Gedanke gewesen der
der dass wir nicht abgerufene Milliarden
die wir als Kreditermächtigungen hatten
für die Bewältigung der coronapandemie
die aber schon durchaus auch eine
Richtung hatten in in Richtung also
konjunkturförderung aber mit Richtung
also dig nein Digitalisierung und
klimaneutral Moment Digitalisierung und
Klimaneutralität war in der
coronaapandemie Bewältigung schon viel
drin also in all diesen all diesen
Bazooka und bums
Maßnahmen zure ne haben gar nichts
zurecht getrickst diese Milliarden sind
nicht abgerufen worden weil die
Wirtschaft wegen Corona so da niederlag
dass die keine Transformation machen
konnten wir hatten z.bpiel Mittel drin
für den flottentausch von sozial
Einrichtung das wurde alles nicht
abgeruen deswegen haben wir deswegen hab
und deswegen haben wir gesagt diese
Mittel sind jetzt nicht eingesetzt
worden wir haben aber die
Kreditermächtigungen schon lass uns die
Übertrag
in einen in einen Fond und und und das
Einsetzen und diese diese diese
Übertragung sagt jetzt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht war nicht war
nicht
verfassungsgemäß genauso wie es auch wie
es auch nicht verfassungsgemäß gewesen
war 2022 die Notlage auszurufen für die
Gas und
strompreisbremse und die dann in 23 und
geplant war ja auch 24 anzuwenden no die
Frage
war war aber bisher ja
gängige Praxis und wurde nicht nur in im
Bund sondern auch in den Ländern so
angewendet das ist das ist wahr aber
allen war klar das ist ein Trick allen
war klar dass das ein Kniff ist ein
Kniff ist um eben ja na ja also sicher
wenn wenn man wenn man wenn man
kreditermächtigung wenn man
Kreditermächtigungen schon hat und muss
keine neuen muss keine neuen beschließen
dann ist es eine Methode wo man wo
man meode
sie versuchen michiningen dass ich
drüber spreche wir wen W
schonpteien sind auf der Grundlage auch
dieses Tricks zusammengekommen Trick
haben sie
benutzt Methode Kniff was ist es es ist
eine Vorgehensweise gewesen die ganz
offensichtlich vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt als
Verfassungs widrig angesehen wird in dem
Urteil das haben wir zuur Kenntnis zu
nehmen und gehen jetzt an ers vor Sie
haben V ist auch nicht passiert die
gesamte Koalition und den gesamten
Haushalt und die nächsten vier Jahre auf
etwas aufgebaut was mit einer
50przentigen Wahrscheinlichkeit
mindestens ihnen vom Verfassungsgericht
weggenommen werden würde und das wusste
man dass es mindestens 50% riskant war
das kann man ja mal machen wenn man ein
guter Spieler ist und gute Nerven hat
aber wieder hat diese Regierung gute
Nerven noch sollte man alles was man hat
auf diese 50% Chance setzen und alles
was haben ist diese Regierung und die
steht und fällt mit diesem Ding also es
sind zwei verschiedene Dinge ist ist
einerseits das Übertragen von mittelen
Ost aus den aus den coronahilfen in den
KTF das hat mit den mit der hat mit der
jährig hat mit der jährigkeit von von
Notlagen nichts zu tun und das andere
war eben der der WSF der wirtschaftsst
stabilisier Milliarden genau ich will
kurz erkären genau wo man davon ausging
und bisher auch davon ausgehen konnte
dass man im einen Jahr die Notlage
erklären kann um dann die Mittel in den
nächsten Jahren zu verwenden jetzt sagt
das Bundes das war das war also ist im
im Grundgesetz nicht so klargelegt wie
wie es jetzt in dem Urteil klargelegt
wurde so und deswegen wissen wir jetzt
wenn wir lang anhaltende Krisen haben
das ist im Urteil auch alles beschrieben
dass es lang langjährige Krisen geben
kann mit unmittelbaren mit mittelbaren
Folgen die der Staat auch dann am Ende
bewältigen muss dass man dann eben jedes
Jahr neu diese Notlage erklären muss
dass auch die Hürden für die Begründung
höher werden und jetzt wo wir es wissen
gehen wir auch entsprechend vor deswegen
haben wir ja jetzt für 23 noch die Not
reden wir gleich drüber was auch
interessant ist ne dass man ein Jahr
rückblickend dann zur Notlage erklärt
das ist schon 22 gewesen Herr was war
das jetzt ein Trick ein Kniff eine
Methode eine Vorgehensweise was nehmen
Sie sie können genauso gut sagen es ist
eine Weiterentwicklung der sich in den
letzten 20 Jahren entwickelnden
haushaltspraxis denn was wir nicht ganz
das was er hören wollte nicht ganz ja
aber es ist Ex wir seit 20 Jahren getrix
nein das ist keine trickerei sondern wir
haben ja die Bewegung wir haben die
Bewegung in den öffentlichen Finanzen
weg von der Kameralistik eigentlich
festzustellen die Gemeinden Kameralistik
ist eine einfache
einnahmenausgabenrechnung ja also sie
jährlich festgehalten wird sie haben die
Einnahmen sie haben die Ausgaben und am
Ende sind Defizit normale Menschen auch
machen wie ist der private Haushalt
vielleicht macht wenn er schon keine
Investition in eine Immobilie hat das
sieht schon bisschen anders aus wenn Sie
ein Unternehmen ne
Unternehmen bildet Rücklagen bildet
Rückstellungen hat gewisse Reserven zur
Verfügung hat aber auf der anderen Seite
genauso auch Fremdkapital das es
aufnimmt am Markt also sich verschuldet
und in diese Richtung sind wir gegangen
wir haben auf der Gemeindeebene im Land
Hamburg wenn ich das so sagen darf in
diesem Stadtstaat im Bundesland Hessen
die doppig eingeführt also sind in diese
Richtung gegangen und insofern muss man
auch sagen es geht eben nicht nur um den
WSF und den KTF also klimafond und
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond es geht
auch um den Fond für die Flutopfer der
atalflut man muss sich jetzt noch mal
überlegen auch nach der heutigen
Anhörung was ist im digitalisierungsfond
und so weiter ich habe noch ein
Vorschlag es war ein Zaubertrick es war
ein Zaubertrick um alles unter einen Hut
zu bringen was sie in den
koalitionsverhandlung eben nicht unter
einen Hut gebracht haben
dann dann brauchten sie 60 frische
Milliarden für diese vier Jahre und noch
diverse andere Umbuchungen mindestens
das ist es ja um all das leisten zu
können was ich die SPD gewünscht hatte
die sich gewünscht hatten und die FP
nicht an Steuererhöhung zubilligen
wollen und das war der Trick alles drei
auf ein man ja gerne so sagen aber es
ist tatsächlich seit 20 Jahren gäige
Praxis und wenn ich sage wir haben in
der großen Koalition mit CDU und CSU
gemeinsamld wir haben mit der mit CDU
und CSU in der großen Koalition
gemeinsam ja auch um um die um die
Wirtschaft in der Situation der
coronapandemie zu stützen aber auch in
die bestimmte Richtung zu entwickeln
eben nicht mehr alte Technologien zu
fördern sondern nach vorne zu schauen
die superabschreibung für digitale
Wirtschaftsgüter und diese Dinge und wie
gesagt der flottentausch dort haben wir
eben solche Mittel schon angesetzt sie
sind aber kaum abgerufen worden weil die
Wirtschaft eben wie gesagt so da
niederlag das kaum was passieren konnte
dann schien es sinnvoll dann schien es
sinnvoll diese diese Mittel eben weiter
zu verwenden das hauptprblem ist einfach
die Übertragung von Kreditermächtigungen
Ermächtigung kann man muss man
grundsätzlich mal sagen wir tun jetzt
ständig so als wäre der Geld plötzlich
weg ist die bessere Formulierung es war
nie
da man hat überhaupt kein Kredit
aufgenommen ja so ja die Kredit sollten
ja aufgenommen werden dann in den
Folgejahren und da muss man ja auch
sagen das ist nicht an der
Schuldenbremse vorbei sondern es ist in
der Ausnahmeregel der Schuldenbremse
aufgenommen und das heißt das was dann
zusätzlich über das was normal erlaubt
ist hinausgeht muss dann später getilt
werden das heißt man verschiebt explizit
in die Zukunft ja explizit für die
nächste Regierung z
ja klar war mir das klar ih war das klar
ja D das das
ver
klar hab die
Hälfte das gesagt dass wir diese
Problematik diskutiert haben war völlig
klar gesagtung 5050 nein ich habe nicht
gesagt das ein Trick aber dass das
durchaus auch eine Möglichkeit ist die
passieren kann dass es verfassungswidrig
ist was hat er gesagt er hat sich bei
allen anderen Vorhaben die es dann gab
im Hinblick auf den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond
Kreditermächtigungen die jetzt nicht
genutzt werden zu nutzen ja dann auch
quer gestellt hat ja klar gesagt das
geht so nicht aber warum ist man denn da
nicht drauf vorbereitet ich meine es ist
man was man auf was keiner vorbereitet
war war die Stärkung der alten
Kameralistik also die Prinzipien von
Jährlichkeit für den für die Planung
jährigkeit für den
vollzugkeit niem eret sie hatten doch
offenbar ich darf Herrn Feld
widersprechen das muss ich jetzt
wirklich tun sie müssen wiersprechen
Herr F wir haben wir haben nicht nicht
Herr Lindner hat sich gesperrt und dann
ist das nicht weiter angewendet worden
sondern im Gegenteil Herr Lindner hat
sich dagegen gesperrt jedes Jahr die
Notlage auszurufen er hat gesagt er will
einen Schuldenbremsen konformen Haushalt
er will keine Ausnahmeregel mehr ziehen
in 23 und deswegen haben wir es 22
gemacht damit es dann für 23 gilt das
also ich habe von Anfang an gesagt wir
sollten auch für die Folgejahre die
ausnahmel Entschuldigung aber darf mal
fragen also Herr Blume auch vielleicht
mal die Frage an Sie als jemand der sehr
nah dran ist auch so eine Leut
ich meine wir reden hier über die viert
oder je nach Lesart ob Japan noch vor
uns ist oder nicht drittgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt wir reden über
sehr viel Geld wir reden über die größte
Transformation der letzten Jahrzehnte
vor der wir stehen und dann tricken wir
rum und erleben jetzt gerade hier Frau
esken sagt na gut haben ein bisschen
getrickt ma seit 20 Jahren Herr F sagt
ich habe den
Bundesfinanzminister bitte in dessen
ressor das passiert ich habe ihm das
gesagt da könnte was schiefgehen und
dann haben wir kein Plan B und keiner
ist wirklich vorbereitet ist das ist das
ist das wie soll man sagen ist das gutes
gutes Handwerk politisches Handwerk ich
glaube das entscheidende Problem ist es
gab nie einen Plan A den Plan B war ja
das mit den Schulden gut da brauch man
auch kein Plan B nein das Plan B war das
mit den Schulden das war ja die
ausweichfinanzierung wenn man so will
des Umstandes oder um dem Umstand
gerecht zu werden wir können uns nicht
darauf einigen was uns ganz wichtig ist
ein bisschen weniger wichtig ist und
nicht so wichtig ist sie könen auch ke
diese Reihenfolge hat diese Koalition
nicht hinbekommen in den
koalitionsverhandlung zumindest nicht in
einem Maße dass das Geld dafür gereicht
hätte und dann hat man es anders
finanziert das ist jetzt weg und darum
stehen sie in Wahrheit vor zweiten
koalitionsverhandlung sie müssen sich
jetzt entscheiden was ihnen wichtiger
ist bestimmte Dinge im Sozialstaat
bestimmte Dinge beim Klimaschutz die
Steuer erhö gich komm wir gleich drauf
ich habe vorher noch eine andere Frage
erfällt an sie Hessen ne weil diese
dieser Zaubertrick von dem ncolas Blum
sprach den gab's ja auch in den Ländern
ne und Hessen hat das auch versucht
mit einem Volumen 12 Milliarden Euro
ging es da und da hat dann der
Landesrechnungshof gesagt ne Freunde so
macht ihr das bitte nicht die sollten
umgewidmet werden bis zum Ende des
Jahres 2023 am Tag des Urteils 27
Oktober da sehen wir das
21 twittert ein gewisser Christian
Lindner das heutige Urteil des
hässischen Staatsgerichtshofs verdient
Beachtung Achtung über Hessen hinaus
beschreibt Kriterien für
kreditfinanzierte Maßnahmen zur
Krisenbewältigung und zeigt der
schwarzgrünen Haushaltspolitik damit
ihre Grenzen auf das heißt da wusste
jemand ganz genau wie viel
taschenspielerreit das ist nein also man
muss natürlich auch sagen nach dem
herischen Urteil kam noch mal ein aus
reinlandfalz das in eine andere Richtung
ging was das Bundesverfassungsgericht
macht unterschlagen ja ich kann Ihnen
sagen ich kann Ihnen sagen wie wir
gemeinsam bei der PR Konferenz für den
sogenannten doppelwums nämlich die den
den Wirtschafts und stabilisierungsfond
die Strom und gaspreisbremse saßen und
wie die Journalisten gefragt haben und
wenn das nicht reicht und wenn nächstes
Jahr weitere Mittel notwendig sindm und
dann haben wir beide sowohl Herr Lindner
als auch ich gesagt dann steht die
Ausnahmeregel von der Schuldenbremse
genauso in der Verfassung wie die
Schuldenbremse selbst und dann sind wir
in der Lage auch in
2023 eben diese Schulden Regel zu ziehen
diese Ausnahmeregel zu ziehen die Fr
weil es eben notwendig ist
Krisenbewältigung Krisenbewältigung in
einem solchen in einem solchen Ausmaß
kann man nicht aus normalhaushalt machen
könen wir haben soziale Krise abgewendet
wir haben eine soziale Krise abgewendet
wir haben eine Wirtschaftskrise
abgewendet wir haben eine
energieversorgungskrise abgewendet da
war wirklich da steckte wirklich viel
Musik drin und da kann man das kann man
nicht aus dem normalhaushalt machen und
dann meinet wegen bei den bei den
Sozialausgaben sparen was jetzt immer
sehr viel diskutiert wird man kann keine
soziale Krise doch kan keine soziale
Krise verhindern ich spreche jetzt von
der damaligen Situation man kann keine
soziale Krise verhindern indem man den
Sozialstaat rasiert das wird wohl nicht
klappen
gasumlage GEG heizungsgesetz
Wärmepumpen jetzt das finden sie es wä
mal an der Zeit einfach mal sorry zu
sagen sich mal zu entschuldigen nicht
Sie persönlich aber vielleicht für den
deutschen Kanzler mal klar zu sagen was
das eigentlich wie fanden sie in dem
Zusammenhang seine letzte
Regierungserklärung fand sie gut ich hab
genau in diesen Zusammenhang gesagt es
war ein Fehler das von Anfang an es war
ein Fehler dass wir 2023 die Schulden
die Ausnahmeregel von der Schuldenbremse
nicht auch gezogen haben den müssen wir
jetzt korrigieren und müssen es
nachholen W wir kurz reinhören in diese
Regierungserklärung dann und dannen wir
einmal drüber die einzige Erklärung die
ich oder Entschuldigung die ich gehört
habe war die von Katharina dröge von den
Grünen die Reg schade dass sie meine
nicht gehört haben ja die die des
Kanzlers hätte mich interessiert und die
Klang ungefähr so wir hören mal kurz
rein dem Wissen um die aktuelle
Entscheidung hätten wir im Winter 2021
andere Wege beschritten Wege die das
Gericht in seinem Urteil ebenfalls
gewiesen
hat wir haben in den vergangenen Tagen
intensiv über die Folgen des Urteils
beraten diese Beratung sind wie sollte
es anders sein noch nicht abgeschlossen
Sorgfalt geht dabei vchnelligkeit
wir lassen niemanden allein mit den
Herausforderungen mit denen wir es
aktuell so geballt zu tun
haben you never walk alone das habe ich
im vergangenen Jahr versprochen und
dabei bleibt
es es geht um die Frage steht jeder für
sich allein wenn es schwierig wird oder
haken wir uns unter ich bin zutiefst
überzeugt wir alle kommen besser zurecht
wenn wir niemanden zurücklassen mit
diesen klaren Prämissen beraten wir
jetzt über den Haushalt für das kommende
Jahr mit der nötigen Ruhe und in
Verantwortung für unser Land darauf
können die Bürger und Bürger sich
verlassen dafür stehe ich als
Bundeskanzler ich danke
ihnen hat sie das beruhigt Frau
Wu ich muss sagen in dieser ganzen Frage
ich bin in Haushaltsfragen nicht
qualifiziert aber was ich sehr
beunruhigend finde ist tatsächlich auch
dieses ganze Gelächter im Parlament ich
finde es schwierig dieses narrativ zu
bedienen dass die Regierung trickst lügt
Dinge überhaupt gar nicht auf die Reihe
kriegt ich glaube dass da massive Fehler
geschehen sind dass S unsere
Entschuldigung anhören müssen das ist
das eine demokratische Problem wenn man
so will dass ich gerade sehe das andere
wie geht es jetzt eigentlich weiter es
wird viel debattiert wo jetzt Einsparung
gemacht werden müssen ob Investitionen
die nicht getätigt werden wo soll das
ganze Geld plötzlich herkommen wer muss
jetzt herhalten dafür wer muss
letztenendes bezahlen dafür so das komm
gleich drauf sie sagen kritisch
nachzufragen und zu sagen da da wird
getrixt ich habe das Wort nicht benutzt
noch mal war die parteichfin der SPD die
das Wort benutzt hat das ist nicht okay
an dem Punkt muss ich doch
Nachfragen natürlich fragen Sie danach
aber ich glaube es hat so ein gewisses
Level erreicht wo ich sage sprechen wir
jetzt gerade über Fehler oder sprechen
wir gerade über Lügen und Betrug und das
ist sehr wissen sie das ist sehr an der
Grenze und ich möchte jetzt gerade auch
keine regierungsverte ade ja es ist ja
nicht trivial ne worum es hier gerade
geht das ist ein ganzes Land massiv
verunsichert über das was da gerade
passiert das ist mein Thema das ist
richtig und deswegen müssen wir über die
Fehler sprechen die Frage ist nur wie
wir in dieser aufgeheizten Stimmung
gerade generell über unsere Regierung
sprechen aber ja ich gehe damit dass wir
über Fehler sprechen müssen Herr Blume
wie sehen Sie das es ist schwierig mit
dem mit diesem Bundeskanzler über Fehler
zu sprechen weil er glaubt dass er
unfehlbar ist und das meine ich jetzt
gar nicht zynisch und lebt in diesem
Selb Selbstbewusstsein dass man wie ein
Panzer manchmal auch und gerade als
Bundeskanzler wahrscheinlich auch
braucht es hat jetzt nur find ich ein
bisschen sehr starke Formen angenommen
sich in den Bundestag zu stellen zu
sagen das ist jetzt nur ein kleiner
Betriebsunfall und wir machen mal in
Ruhe weiter so ist tatsächlich zu
einfach also die Bundeskanzlerin über
die man auch viel lästern kann oder viel
auch Kritisches sagen kann Angela Merkel
hat sich unmittelbar also noch im
Wahljahr Ost ist Stich ausgerufen und
das war dann wirklich auch ein
vollkommener Griff daneben und musste
sich dann aber hat das eben auch überb
sich gebracht sich dann öffentlich
einmal dafür zu entschuldigen und zu
sagen okay da habe ich mich
verrannt und ich glaube das würde den
diesen Bundeskanzler auch gar nichts
kosten von dem was ihm an Reputation
geblieben ist sondern ich glaube es
würde ihn eher Stärken in der Rolle ja
Himmel dann müssen wir halt jetzt
aufräumen wir haben das versucht ich
glaube immer noch ungefähr die Hälfte
der Experten hat gesagt das könnt ihr
probieren das kann klappen die andere
hat gesagt das wir aber echt heikel lass
es mal besser bleiben und dann haben die
halt drauf gesetzt okay sie hätten
natürlich wissen müssen wenn es schief
geht machen wir es wie folgt mein Punkt
ist wenn du wenn du sagst die Hälfte
sagt das könnte klappen und die andere
Hälfte sagt ist schwierig sorry das wird
einem Land wie Deutschland wirklich
nicht gerecht muss man doch drauf
vorbereitet sein kann man nicht ein
vorbereitet sein und man muss auch
anstatt a den Untergang des
Sozialstaates auszurufen B das Ende
allen Klimaschutzes oder C den Untergang
des Abendlandes müsste man sagen okay
das ist Loch das Loch ist so groß und
das kriegen wir jetzt in binen zwei
Wochen solid zu ob nur mit mehr
Einnahmen oder mit weniger Ausgaben oder
mit einer Mischung aus beidem das kann
ja verdammt noch mal nicht so schwierig
sein wirklichen Regierungskrise führt
und das werden sie nicht bestreiten von
es das ist eine Regierungskrise das ist
keine Regierungskrise nein wä das nicht
jetzt Moment was ist den dann was ist es
dann was ist es dann es ist die
Erkenntnis genauso wie der Bundeskanzler
es vorgetragen hat es ist die Erkenntnis
dass die Art und Weise wie wir unsere
Haushalte und auch die die die Fonds und
und Sondervermögen gestaltet haben
Sondervermögen sind wieder so ein Wort
Sondervermögen ist ein anderes Wort für
bitte sprechen ich lass sie sprechen
aber das ist ein Fachbegriff okay und
die heißen so ja ich überset für die die
zuschauen Sondervermögen sch ich glaube
es ist mittlerweile eingeführt soweit es
gibt auch ein Sondervermögen es gibt ein
Sondervermögen für den digitalpakt
beispielsweise der ist auch aufgelegt
worden um eben eben über mehrere Jahre
Sondervermögen über mehere genau um über
mehrere Jahre hinweg noch dazu in
Zusammenarbeit mit den Ländern eine
wichtige Aufgabe
anzugehen wo die Länder auch Sicherheit
haben müssen dass es über eine
Legislaturperiode hinweg gesichert ist
we es gibt Sondervermögen seit den 50er
Jahren ne und ich glaub ungefähr 20 aber
Sondervermögen ich weiß nicht warum ich
warum ich jetzt nicht ausführen ja so
die Situation ist die dass die die
Bundesregierung die ampelregierung auf
der Grundlage von diesen Sondervermögen
eben auch dem Klima und
transformationsfond dem Wirtschafts und
stabilisierungsfond ihre Politik
organisiert hat neben dem Haushalt der
Haushalt der für die normalen Ausgaben
zuständig ist der WSF für eine
Krisenbewältigung der KTF eben für die
die die Transformation steckt ja schon
im Wort und jetzt erkennen muss dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht präzisiert in
in Bezug auf die Schuldenbremse dass
diese Vorgehensweise nicht okay ist dass
die nicht der Verfassung entspricht und
deswegen werden wir jetzt ein anderen
Haushalt astellen und wir werden beides
auch weiterhin ermöglichen
Krisenbewältigung Investitionen in die
Transformation denn das muss sein das
ist dringend notwendig Millionen von
Arbeitsplätzen hängen davon ab dass wir
auch Vorankommen mit der Transformation
und deswegen müssen wir
Finanzierungsmodelle finden die eben
jetzt anders sind als die die wir bisher
für richtig gehalten haben nichts
anderes hat der Bundeskanzler gesagt er
hat gesagt im im wissen dieses Urteils
hätten wir anders gehandelt jetzt haben
wir so gehandelt jetzt müssen wir die
die Vorgehensweise ändern und das werden
wir auch tun und da gibt's auch keine
Regierungskrise sondern da sitzen jetzt
drei zusammen und Sie können sicher sein
dass die drei auch mit ihren jeweiligen
Parteien sehr engen Kontakt sind und
dass wir dann gemeinsam zu einer Lösung
kommen da wird ein Koalitionsausschuss
am Ende stattfinden und dann werden
kommen die dran die deren
Königsdisziplin der Haushalt ist nämlich
das Parlament da sitzt der Ökonom das
Parlament ist die sind die mit der
Königsdisziplin all das was wir gerade
besprechen löst eine tiefe
Verunsicherung in diesem Land aus die
Investitionen
sind dramatisch abgefallen ist richtig
ne investistätigkeit ist schwach in
Deutschland das hat aber sehr viele
andere Kunde die nichts damit zu tun
haben sag ja Insolvenzen gestiegen um
23% stark in der Bauwirtschaft WE in der
Bauwirtschaft
Textilbranche Marken wie pcon
klottenburg und andere ger WE gibt es
alles nicht mehr und so weiter äh ich
will nur sagen also das ist ja alles
nicht trivial worüber wir hier reden
Wärmepumpen habe ich mir mal angeguckt
auch interessant im vergangenen Jahr
150.000 Anträge im vergangenen Jahr für
neue Wärmepumpen jetzt haben wir es
geschafft das Land so zu verunsichern
dass wir gerade 76 000 Anträge haben in
diesem Land was sagt uns das die Leute
warten bis das Gesetz verabschiedet ist
und sie dann die genauen Bedingungen
kennen das ist halt immer noch nicht
verabschiedet das meine ich ja Leute
wissen nicht woran sie sind also das
gebäudeenerg würde ich jetzt aber auch
nicht mit dem Haushalt in einem Topf
werfen weil das doch zwei
unterschiedliche Dinge sind denn beim
gebäudeenergiegesetz gab es doch so
viele unterschiedliche Positionen dass
es schwierig war zu einer gemeinsamen zu
kommen das hat lange gedauert ist er
noch nicht durch während jetzt beim
Haushalt am 15 November ist entschieden
worden der Nachtragshaushalt 2023 also
für das jetzt laufende Jahr wird jetzt
noch in Kürze verabschiedet werden der
Haushalt 2024 vielleicht no noch vor
Weihnachten und ich teile Ihre Ansicht
nicht abblome dass es die Regierung in
eine tiefe Regierungskrise stürzt wenn
wir erst im Januar darüber entscheiden
würden im Deutschen Bundestag ähm man
muss das schon auch äh wirklich jetzt
sorgfältig anschauen was alles an
Veränderung nötig ist die Überraschung
war wirklich diese Festlegung auf
Jährlichkeit und jährigkeit damit haben
nicht mal die Kläger gerechnet und
insofern kann den Plan B da sein wenn
ein Urteil kommt was für die Zukunft
Veränderungen bringt aber nicht wenn ein
Urteil kommt da sagt ihr müsst jetzt
auch rückwirkend alles noch einmal
ändern ja ich ich bleib da M ein anderer
Satz aufgefallen in dieser
Regierungserklärung eigentlich sogar
zwei deswegen fragt die vorhin auch mal
nach einer Entschuldigung und nach einer
Erklärung
Olaf Scholz sagt das Gericht hat hier
das letzte Wort das ist gute
demokratische Tradition und im nächsten
Satz schon relativiert er das wieder und
sagt wissenschaftlich mag das Urteil
weiter diskutiert werden politisch ist
die Diskussion damit beendet das heißt
übersetzt eigentlich hatte ich recht äh
und der und der zweite Satz ist oder
nicht
ein Wissenschaftler ist er diskutiert
nicht wissch Entschuldigung der man
kennt sich aus er ist Jurist und das
zweite ist Jurist ist was anderes als
ein Wissenschaftler sind also da da
werden Verfassungsrechtler Mö
möglicherweise noch drüber diskutieren
aber die Politik diskutiert nicht mehr
gibt noch ein zweiten Satz gibt noch
einen zweiten Satz er sagt eine Realität
also er sagt dieses Urteil schaffe eine
neue Realität eine Realität die es
schwieriger macht wichtige Ziele für
unser Land zu erreichen und da fragt man
sich als als Bürger der vom Fernseher
sitzt hat wann ist das Grundgesetz eine
neue
Realität nicht das Grundgesetz sonder
das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
hat eine Präzisierung geschaffen die
klar gemacht hat dass die bishere Praxis
nicht mehr geht und das das ist eine
neue Realität selbstverständlich es wäre
auch für die Vorgängerregierung eine
andere Realität gewesen wenn dieses
Urteil in der Zeit der groko gefät
worden wäre denn auch dann wären dort
bestimmte Dinge nicht mehr gegangen die
man da so gemacht hat okay das macht es
auch nicht schwierig
ist ja auch die wirtschaftliche
Situation die sie beschreiben die ist
doch nicht in den vergangenen zwei oder
drei Wochen entstanden nein das
ich aber Wirtschaft braucht doch
Sicherheit und muss doch wissen wie es
weiter geht Investitionssicherheit und
all diese Dinge der Denkfehler in dem
Satz ist doch dieses Urteil macht es
jetzt schwerer Politik zu machen ich
würde sagen es ist genau andersrum
dieses Urteil zwingt sie endlich Politik
zu machen und sich zu entscheiden was
Ihnen wichtig ist was wichtig für dieses
Land ist aus ihrer mehrheitlich gewäh
sind wir beim Thema sind wir beim Thema
und was nicht so wichtig ist dieses
Urteil hat den Zustand beendet wo sie
alles machen konnten was ihnen
eingefallen ist und das geht jetzt halt
nicht mehr würde ich auch ganz
entschieden Wieders sprechen denn
Krisenbewältigung Krisenbewältigung wird
weiterhin möglich sein weil die
Ausnahmeregel weiter entsteht und dann
gibt es mittlerweile eine wachsende
Anzahl von Ökonomen also
Wissenschaftlern aber auch von
Politikern die der Auffassung sind dass
die Schuldenbremse so wie sie heute ist
nicht dazu geeignet ist die Zukunft zu
gestalten nämlich gerade in der Frage
unterscheiden wir eigentlich zwischen
Investitionshaushalt und und
Verwaltungshaushalt Vermögenshaushalt
und
Verwaltungshaushalt wie es in Kommunen
aber aber es ist doch klar dass wir dass
wir nicht nur dann investieren können
wenn wenn wenn es uns die die die
Schuldenbremse erlaubt sondern wir
müssen wir müssen investieren in der
Situation wo es eben notwendig ist
schauen Sie sich an was wir für für ein
Sanierungsstau in den Schulen haben
beispielsweise 50 Milliarden Euro
Sanierungsstau in den Schulen und wir
wir schauen zu und sagen na ja da müssen
wir eben noch ein paar Jahre warten bis
es wirtschaftlich besser läft
das für die Sanierung der Schulen ist in
2017 hingestellt worden und er ist immer
noch nicht abgeflossen also bevor sie in
ein dysfunktionales System von
Verwaltung auch der Länder noch mehr
Milliarden Gießen nehmen Sie doch
erstmal das Geld was da bzw halten Sie
die Länder an und die Kommunen doch mal
das Geld zu nehmen was da ist absolut
also sie wissen schon dass es ich habe
jetzt die Schulden die Schulen als im im
im sanierungsstraum genannt weil weil da
der Betrag Betrag auch klar ist aber wir
haben wir haben ja wir haben ja auch
jetzt die die den Transformation der
Industrie zu unterstützen so wie es eben
viele andere Volkswirtschaften in in in
der ganzen Welt auch tun wenn wir wenn
wir dort wenn wir dort nur hinter wenn
wir dort nur hinterherlfen natürlich wir
müssen in die infr müssention das schon
untersched erklären sie mal bitte den
Unterschied der Unterschied zwischen
Investition und Subvention be bei der
Investition schaffe ich über Inv über
Zahlungen in die Infrastruktur ein
Kapitalstock für dieses Land der dann
auch genutzt werden kann bei den
Subventionen für die Industrie
insbesondere für die altendustrie etwa
Stahl bezahle ich der stahlindustri
einen Betrag den sie irgendwie einsetzt
ob sie das so einsetzt dass sie nachher
auch wirklich als Unternehmen noch am
Markt bleibt oder nicht ist eine ganz
andere Frage intel ist eine weitere Form
dieser Subvention die dann eben auch
schwierig wird 10 Milliarden für Intel
also fast 2 Millionen pro Arbeitsplatz
der geschaffen wird und da muss man sich
fragen was macht denn die Firma damit
hat sie damit bessere Möglichkeiten
angesichts ihrer im Moment nicht ganz
ja ordentlichen Situation s sind ja
relativ prekär äh am Markt unterwegs
sich so zu sanieren dass sie ihren
Anteilseignern mehr auszahlen
kann ich würde weder Intel investieren
noch würde ich diese riesigen Beträge an
die altindustrien Zahlen um Ihnen die
Transformation in die
kliman was ist denn das für ein Begriff
altindustrien Herr F das verstehe ich
jetzt nicht ganz mit welchem mit welchem
Stahl bauen wir dann künftig unsere
Autos oder unsere Maschinen hab jederit
die Möglichkeit Stahl von außen zu
importieren Sie m
m
hab machen wir uns in Zukunft abhängig
bisher waren wir z.B abhängig von
günstiger Energie aus Russland künftig
sind wir dann abhängig von grünem Stahl
aus von wo kommt der dann aus den USA
beispielsweise also wir sind nicht
abhängig davon die Abhängigkeiten die
sie beschreiben sind in den meisten
Produkt Investition die investi in die
halbliterindustrie hier in Europa dass
die sich hier niederlässt und auch bei
uns in Deutschland das ist Investition
in unsere
Unabhängigkeit das eleld eine inves die
zukun
kinderenabhängigkeiten wie wir sie wie
wir sie dadurch dass all ver nach Hause
zu holen das funktioniert so nicht wir
haben doch eine massive Überinvestition
in die Halbleiterindustrie weltweit aus
dieser Sorge heraus dass China Taiwan
angreifen könnte und mit diesen in USA
in Frankreich in Deutschland in anderen
europäischen Ländern sorgen wir dafür
dass Taiwan sogar noch viel stärker dem
chinesischen Aggressor ausgesetzt
wird überhaupt NS davon dieser Art von
und Weise von autarchiebestrebungen zu
unterstützen und es ist keine
Investition es sind Subventionen und am
Ende werden wir uns fragen müssen wie
viel Geld haben wir da eigentlich
versenkt